okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier
don't worry that scared me too I just
loaded up the game and this is bull
violence or wave violence type your name
and then hit enter okay cool
your name oh cool my name is barely mark
tank cool ass and your profession master
wave thief okay
your mission pretty damn important
infiltrate the mansion construction site
steal the MacGuffin and get out alive
you are very fragile but you are handed
the ultimate weapon hand waves you and I
did there
pull out your head by holding the right
mouse button then wave with the left
mouse button your sheer politeness will
little bit what this is do see the
weapon is a very short Iver we used to
consider etcetera right that's all bye
Oh what oh my god that top-down map
locate and steal the MacGuffin hi oh
I've been caught that didn't do it
whoops okay so apparently I'm supposed
to be stealthy about it oh oh no man
hello oh okay that didn't work my way
didn't work Wow Wow
Wow okay all right whatever this game
remind me burrito galaxy in a way oh it
says slapping burritos you're blowing up
guards with a wave of your hand
Oh Hidy Hidy Hidy Hidy Hidy ho the top
down is important I should look at that
hey you shouldn't stand there ha you
ready wait please
hey okay right he holdin so that's how
oh oh I can I can I can I can indeed
okay all right then well you guys our
days are numbered then oh you think you
can stop me from stealing your MacGuffin
well I don't think Oh quick like ah [ __ ]
I should risk that all right I get it
BAM [ __ ] where are you taking me sir
excuse you Oh oh [ __ ] you oops it's
supposed to be possible my bad oh my oh
my name is Mark number one cool ass all
right now I got this enough goofing
around I'll take the cool more seriously
fine
what's up back okay well toast me to
victory apparently apparently I'm just
gonna ride this one out
hey how's it going guys hey remember how
I said I was going to stop digging
around well alas it is not that way I've
got a mobile platform here Wow
okay who's gonna died means that the
MacGuffin this is the MacGuffin hello
ah all right okay
now I'll do it properly there we go yeah
you got to be like on them
okay so there's another patrol coming
around that corner I need to stay nice
and stealthy I can either do this one of
two ways I could avoid them or I could
just blast them all into oblivion
oh no you thought you were gonna go home
to your family where are you going all
so wet why why okay that wasn't supposed
to go that way man it didn't have to go
down like that you made me do that that
was not my fault I'm gonna steal that
MacGuffin would you think you can keep
the MacGuffin for me I don't know how
you did that or why the AI is very
sensitive here I lucked out on those
MacGuffin blasts but I can't get so
lucky all the time
I gotta actually take this seriously
which I happen believe it or not this is
me taking it seriously
oh god someone's coming ooh doodly-doo
doodly-doo doodly-doo doodly-doo I don't
know how far he's gonna come this way
but if he comes this way enough to get a
blast both hand I'm gonna hand them
right in the act I'm just gonna smack
that ass I hope for the best
oh who knew that markiplier zas Pat's
we're going to be so devastating ready
for you oh your mistake you did what I
told you to do that was your first
mistake
this is your second
[Music]
haha they're pretty blind okay pretty
blind so long as you're drunk
oh that had more range dude why did that
have definite step [ __ ] come on [ __ ] you
want some of this here oh here their
supply baby okay so being crashed us how
and it's so good touch up such a such a
shocking thing
oh you coming out to inspect the flag
okay alright then
okay oh I don't know how you did that
maybe methinks this game wasn't perfect
we got incoming
oh right this mug up in his mind you
come over here your dad you don't wanna
do this you don't wanna dance you don't
wanna do yeah okay I got it I'm on the
run oh I got it I think I got it don't
come after me don't come after me don't
come after me we will we will will will
will will
yeah he'll I acquired the MacGuffin you
can now continue on unspecified plans
look I'm really drunk we just have a
game here thank you
I'm going to bed oh goodness
Oh game by Allen dancing Jen
dancing Genji Carmen with music by math
Noll Gordon Warren oh oh well that's way
violent if the concept is cool like it's
obviously rudimentary but the style that
you put into it like my god that was
really legitimately cool I enjoyed that
a lot
probably more than I should have but I
did oh man either way that is will
violin thank you everybody so much for
watching you can check out this game
through going to the description below
let me know what you thought of it down
in the comments and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]